hey guys it is Friday once again which
means it's time to fill you in on all
the important things that happened in
gaming this week here's the good stuff
so stopping things that aren't actually
gaming but people seem to unanimously
care about Disney have revealed when you
can get star wars the force awakens in
your home the blockbuster will be out in
home video form from the Disney movies
anywhere service on April one and on
blu-ray and DVD on april five the extras
will include a behind-the-scenes look
into the making of the movie cast
interviews building bb-8 and creating
creatures a deeper look at the battle
between ray and kylo ren's deleted
scenes and a bunch of other bits and
pieces to help you get your force
awakens fix although it's still
officially unannounced the titles all
true pops up in gamestop this week
twitter you the nile mayor post up a
picture from the store that shows up a
row of titanfall 2 boxes although the
game can't be found on the retailer's
website yet titanfall 2 was confirmed as
in production a year ago but neither
respawn or EA have made an official
announcement about the game the sequel
is believed to be a multi-platform
release unlike the first game which was
exclusive to xbox consoles and PC
earlier this month it was also revealed
possibly unintentionally by toy maker
MacFarlane that it's Twilight based on
titanfall would arrive later this year
alongside titanfall to the ps4 the next
major system update was detailed this
week and here's what's on the way the
3.5 hour firmware update will now let
you appear offline include remote play
for PCs and Mac's which will let you use
your ps4 by our computer schedule a
session for the party of friends and
check out what your party are up to so
you can join games easier according to
Sony the beta for the update will roll
out to a selection of users soon but no
release date has been announced as yet
earlier this week and game crusher
discovered that far cry primal geography
is similar to that of Bahrain for like
really really similar the world's
massive Far Cry primal appears to very
closely replicate the topography of the
map from Far Cry or a little
a source close to Ubisoft confirmed to
kotaku that far cry primal Deb's used
the Far Cry 4 height maps as quote a
basis for their game lazy developing or
a clever reference to what the map may
have looked like 10,000 years earlier
you tell me finally uncharted 4 has been
delayed for the third time president and
CEO of sony computer entertainment Sean
Layden wrote in an effort to meet the
considerable worldwide demand and to
ensure that all gamers worldwide have
the opportunity to play the game on day
one we've chosen to postpone the launch
of the game by two weeks to allow for
extra manufacturing time the game will
now land on May 10 of this year
hopefully this week on site I tell you
about a bunch of sweet remasters that
are on their way this year we reviewed
Twilight Princess HD and explain how no
man's sky actually plays those are all
the things I wanted to tell you about
this week but as always be sure to have
yourselves a great weekend they will
catch you again on Monday
you